good morning everyone good afternoon
good evening from wherever you are
watching this uh this is deepam paul and
with me is my co-presenter alan krita
tiwari um
we are delighted to be here at pi data
global and
we are going to present on the topic
today uh anyone can do this
solving the minority class imbalance
problem once and for all
um so yeah without much further ado
let's dive in uh these are like the you
know some of the items that we'll touch
upon throughout our talk
and this is just to like set the
expectations we will go in a very
step-by-step approach with the entire
discussion so even if you have little to
no experience i don't think you should
have a problem but of course having a
little helps but yeah these are some of
the things that we'll go over okay
so before we begin uh this is like a
small introduction
uh uh this is me deepam i am from
calcutta i
have as it's written and always
passionately curious about you know
knowing about different things building
things uh exploring things
and yeah that's just me on a nice beach
uh over to my co-author
uh hello everybody it's great to be here
so my name is alan krita and i am from
india
and apart from the things that you
cannot really make out about me
from what's given in front of you
uh the other thing to know about me is
that i
like to you know learn about new stuff
especially related to deep learning
machine learning and this is something
that
i have been doing for quite some time
now and this
uh
i was also a part of pi data global last
year as well that is 2020 and have had
the opportunity to
you know be a part of various
conferences
uh you know all around the world where i
get to meet new people and learn new
stuff so
that's something that i really look
forward to
now
moving on what exactly are we doing here
and what is the problem here that we are
trying to mitigate
so before we
dive deep into that i would want to
touch upon
what do we mean by class when
we talk about deep learning
so
i
probably take an example that everybody
every one of us must have heard of you
know at some point in their lives while
figuring out deep learning and that is
the famous
dog and
cat and dog's classification problem
so now in that case the images of all
these dogs from different species and
like different breeds
uh when they're all clubbed together so
that forms a single class and similarly
for the cat's men so all these different
uh you know different colored cats and
with different eye colors and different
features and they all of them are like
luck together under a different class
that is cats
so
when do we actually face the class
imbalance that we are focusing on
or emphasizing on
about
so this happens when these two classes
in my example
or you know a multiple or in the case of
a multiple or multi-class setup when
there's a class that has you know
relatively very low amounts of data as
compared to the other class or classes
so that is when we face green class
imbalance problem and why is it such a
huge issue
uh that is because
machine learning or deep learning
is a kind of you know technology or is a
thing where the model learns from you
know
the data that you feed it or the data
that it is trained on so now if in our
example let's say we have you know
one cat image for every 20 dog images
so when we and it's been trained on that
for like multiple cycles multiple epochs
and when we try to test that model with
let's say
an unseen image something that the model
has not been trained on so there's a
very high probability of the model
or of the you know our uh vr model
giving back a wrong result so
misclassifying or misidentifying
image because of you know the
inadequate data that it had that it had
to train upon so that is why this
problem is something that
you know just brings down the efficiency
or the quality of a lot of different
models and is something that we facebook
faced and what could be the reason of
this class imbalance there are
or there could possibly be n number of
reasons when it comes to this so the
ones that are the most obvious or the
ones that are the most common that i
would want to touch upon is the fact
of gold standard of labeling so now this
happens when annotators manually you
know label data so
they're not 100 percent right
you know all the time and that in case
can sort of you know cause
uh
the gas imbalance and this has to do
with human error and this is something
that
is there has always been there now
moving on though one other very common
reason could be the fact that we do not
have you know adequate data
for the specific kind of class as
compared to the other classes that we
are sort of you know comparing it
against so this is something that
commonly happens with you know medical
image data and
yeah medical data and that is something
that and that is how we sort of you know
landed on this problem or like on the
first place so uh it was back when my
author and i we were sort of working on
a project
where we had to
classify good for uh sperm cell images
from bad sperm cell images
based on their quality spots and
morphology
so now the problem that we essentially
faced here was for every 8 9 10 bags
from cell images we only had one good
sperm cell in it so when we tried to you
know build a model around using that
data without any kind of interference
from our part through data augmentation
using gans or you know any other methods
so the model was performing very poorly
and that is when you know it hit us that
we have to you know look into it because
this could open a lot of different
avenues for
a lot of people like us
so this is the proposed pipeline which
was based on the project that i talked
about so after redistributing the data
into the specific classes we
actually
went ahead and you know prepared data we
use
different kinds of image enhancement
techniques in order to uh you know
enhance our images to make sure that
you know the features of our images are
you know well understood by the model
and
which in turn helps us get better
results and better performance and makes
our model more robust
so moving on this step the data
augmentation step using cbc gan
was the game changer for us and is
something that me and my co-author will
you know dive into deeper at some later
point in the present
now the last step that we did was after
augmenting our
you know data we trained the uh
classifier using like drain the model on
the classifier densenet 121 and we sort
of chose this
among different classifiers street
training classifiers such as resnet 50
gdg16 all of that based you know simply
based on the kind of results that we
were getting so for our images or for
our data it was yielding the best
results with this specific classifier so
that is why we went ahead with this that
was the specific reason behind
you know choosing them
and now once we are done with the
training we validated our model using
the uh
or employing the threshold technique now
this technique is something that is you
know needed when we talk about class and
balance
and you know data and models that deal
with class and balance so here what we
do is we sort of you know put a
threshold as the name suggests on the
parameters that we're dealing with so
that you know we get the values within a
specific range which is something that's
important and the why of it i'm sure my
co presenter will cover in a shot
and moving on we sort of
we sort of dealt dealt with the uh
evaluation of the set model where we
had to check the quality scores or
uh you know to make sure the performance
was up-to-date and the
for zero were nothing but
the number of good sperm cell images
upon the combined total that is uh the
number of bad sperm cell images and the
goods from seven so
yeah that is what we did
yeah thank you for that so um now like i
think moving on to the most uh crucial
part of the entire uh you know uh
presentation which which is basically
what the presentation is about
so
this is the solution that we are
essentially proposing it's a conditional
deeply convoluted generative adversarial
networks or series again
um so to introduce our audience to this
particular network we have a generator
network and a discriminator network here
as is prevalent in your any ordinary uh
gan
uh but the difference is that we use
multiple uh you know generators and
multiple discriminators which is why uh
it's it's deeply convoluted uh
the the function of the loss function is
also different here than your ordinary
gans when we try to optimize a normal
gain with any loss function it's a
little different here and the most
important part is i think the first c
which is the conditional which actually
allows us to
uh targetedly generate images of a
particular class which is essentially
the problem statement here and which is
obviously a very very difficult task
with
your
ordinary gans or any other variations of
gans um because you have random images
generated uh you know
in in those cases of the entire dataset
okay
so now moving on with that in mind uh we
have this particular idea so why did we
essentially choose this to be the focal
point of our entire project or
presentation and not something else
because uh as i already mentioned this
targeted class or in some cases classes
uh image generation which which actually
is uh you know cakewalk with this
particular network it's basically
designed for that one could say
um
secondly consistent performance of
course like we tried different other uh
you know uh artificially image
generating algorithms such as you know
other variations of gans cans itself the
simple gan architecture we have also
used something of the cell the semi
supervised sort of learning which is
variation your variational autoencoders
so even even then uh of course series
again in this particular problem
statement and
the idea is to you know put this problem
statement into account and treat this as
something which is a part of a much
bigger problem which is the minority
class imbalance problem that is seen
everywhere so series again performed
extremely well here as well
so
now thirdly we also perform cross
validation with like the other other
other architectures that we used and
even there uh our our chosen
architecture which is the conditional
deeply convoluted can performs the most
superior uh so that's that's
possibly you know that that summed up
the reasons why we were certain that we
would go ahead with this and not
something else
um so yeah moving on i think my
co-author also mentioned about this in
the pipeline that when when she was you
know presenting uh so this is a
technique i think which is which is uh
already a little known in in you know uh
types of problems like this uh so we
have a
technique called threshold tuning where
in we
generally use this technique in class
imbalance problems or like when we are
dealing with data sets which like has
a huge amount of class imbalance or a
moderate amount of class imbalance
depending upon that so it's a technique
to basically you know like set different
uh
uh you know ranges for different
parameters and and not allow them to you
know cross a certain threshold that that
that we as a programmer or deep learning
engineer would set
the idea is that you know uh your normal
perception of how training works or how
metrics work is is fine as long as
uh you are dealing with a data set which
is perfectly balanced or more or less
balanced but if if it's not then then
your sort of idea changes and there are
some differences there are some changes
that you have to make in your pipeline
as well
and therefore this this particular
technique comes in really useful because
this not just allows us to uh set a
range within which the parameters would
function but also helps us to not let
the you know class with all classes with
more number of examples outperform the
one that that actually has less number
of examples because that's a that's
that's not a very desirable scenario um
lastly one more important point i would
ask my audience to take a note of is
that when we talk about uh you know
unbalanced data sets or imbalance data
sets uh accuracy is often treated as a
very misleading metric which is which is
because you know you you have an
accuracy for an entire data set so if a
particular class doesn't have enough
examples as my co-author also pointed
out uh you generally don't seem to get a
very very decent picture of how your
model performed on the data set if you
just consider accessing so in in this
particular type of problems uh geometric
mean and f1 scores are sort of metrics
that are preferred in fact over accuracy
so yeah that's that's basically it so we
are trying to reduce the bios from the
entire you know matrix that we use so
that's the result of the employment of
this particular technique and
choosing of the metrics which i think my
co-author will sort of go into
yep
now talking about the validity of the
proposed method as you can see in front
of you we have two different graphs the
first one being the roc con where the
area that we get for it is
approximately 0.92 which again is in
lines of something that we sort of
wanted and
from our model to work you know towards
and similarly for the precision recall
curve you can see the area was nearing
0.89
which again is a pretty good score
now moving on we what we did was we sort
of trained our models twice once with
the you know
deployment of gang and the second one
the second time without it as you can
see we barefoot cross-validated it for
like both the case
so what we noticed was that the bfd
train accuracy or the validation
accuracy both were considerably high and
better in the
uh you know in the case where we did uh
deploy the cdc gang which in turn
strengthens our you know
our pipeline or our proposed methodology
in this specific case and as my
co-presenter also stressed upon accuracy
not being a very
uh you know very reliable metrics in a
case of my immunology class imbalance so
we went ahead and you know took into
consideration some other
metrics as well as well be the f1 score
the roc auc score best threshold all the
test accuracy
uh for all of these metrics the
model or the time where we did deploy
cvc gan outperformed the other time with
a great margin
so that in turn did sort of solidify
our idea or our you know intention
behind going ahead and using the cdc can
yeah i think like that's that's very
important to note because like the
margin that we see here especially in
test accuracy even if you consider
accuracy to be a metric it's it's huge
right if you do not have the artificial
examples generated for the minority
class the the difference is so if you do
not have it it's not even something that
you would use because 24 percent
accuracy is uh you know accurate
inaccurate most of the times so that's
that's not very desirable so yeah
finally i think moving on uh at last we
have cdc again as a technique especially
it's very useful when you are talking
about a real world approach to train an
architecture when you have a data which
is
imbalanced which is often most data sets
if you think about it uh if they're
collected on a practical basis and not
already artificially generated um and
yeah it's a very useful technique if you
want to generate high quality annotated
images and
yeah use the same architecture you know
fit a classified at the end uh like we
did with densenet 121 and have the high
quality annotated images come out of the
you know architecture and finally train
them uh we have higher f1 scores than
any other architectures that we possibly
could experiment with uh especially in
this case which was you know a very
heavy amount of imbalance and lastly
there are a lot of randomness that our
generative adversarial network brings
brings when you're actually training
with it uh but uh
you know surprisingly enough cdc did not
have that and we could you know
targetedly uh generated a lot of high
quality images which were directly
useful in the feature selection process
in the training of the classifier
so yeah it's it's overall i think the
winner of all the approaches that we you
know sort of experimented with and
that's
obviously the reason why you are you
know uh listen to this presentation uh
yeah
so yeah thank you uh i guess that's
that's probably it from our end and uh
you can obviously reach out to us at any
of these email ids if you have any
questions any any uh concerns or any
further extensions to what we did and
yeah thank you patricia global and i
hope to you know of course see you next
year and over to my co-presenter
yeah so i would like to take this
opportunity to thank the organizers and
all the hard-working people who are
the backbone of events like these which
bring together
uh you know so many like-minded people
from all across the world
and having said that i would definitely
want to encourage each and every one of
you to like hit us up with any doubts
questions that you have or even for a
you know simple fun chat so i guess that
would be fun thank you thank you so much